[Music]
the 2010s was the decade of the
superhero movie we saw the first three
phases of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
along with a bunch of on-screen
appearances of heroes from DC the x-men
and even Pixar here are the top moments
and scenes from superhero movies in the
last decade just leave her alone
everything will be fine
the anti superhero film kick-ass helped
usher in the decade of the superhero the
movie is probably remembered for this
scene where the 11 year old Hit Girl
takes out an entire room of henchmen the
r-rated superhero flick didn't start and
stop there oh oh hello 2016's Deadpool
was an envelope pushing smash did I
leave the stove on the movies opening
car chase truly exemplifies the spirit
of the film where you have Deadpool just
breaking the fourth wall to talk to the
audience while taking out the bad guys
will say Ryan Reynolds's third attempt
at being in a superhero movie went a lot
better the x-men prequel started off
really strong early in the decade and
then ended on a disastrous note let's
just cherish this shot in Quicksilver
time which is one of the coolest
slow-motion shots since the matrix is
bullet time
[Music]
the Superfund sequel rightfully teamed
up Scott Lang and hope van die the
movies most memorable scene comes when
the wasp has to fend for herself in the
kitchen meat tenderizers are flying at
her she has to shrink and grow and deal
with all these other related kitchen
objects and it's really a chance for
eventually in Lily to shine
[Music]
marble waited way too long to make its
first female superhero movie 11 years
into the MCU the studio delivered
Captain Marvel and gave us this scene
showing everybody why Carol Danvers is
the most powerful hero in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Carol is being held
by the supreme intelligence Rip's out
our power dampener and delivers this
line
I'm crying Lisa great then she fully
powers up into her binary form and we
see just how powerful Captain Marvel
really is four Guardians we could have
gone with Groot dancing or even quill
dancing but sometimes a memorable moment
it's not even about the characters take
this scene where the Guardians fly into
the lawless nowhere and David Boies
moonage daydream is blasting on the
soundtrack not only is it full of
Awesome establishing shots further
building out Marvel's galactic on-screen
presence but unknown to us at the time
it also sets up the location of a
pivotal scene from an infinity war
freak out far out indeed
[Music]
speaking of sweeping landscapes how
about the first glimpse of Atlantis in
Aquaman who could have thought the
Atlantis of the comics can be brought to
life so vividly just watch the giant
tortoises and whales flying over your
head and let your imagination run wild
bonus points to this movie for including
a few things constantly mocked about
Aquaman and making them kind of Awesome
okay not gonna turn invisible selecting
a bagel
spider-man you know that's funny I get
that a lot
spider-man had a very weird decade he
was portrayed by multiple actors and was
the subject of a massive fight between
two rival studios this was one of the
high points of spider-man on the big
screen in fact into the spider-verse
even picked up the Oscar for Best
Animated Film want to know why this
movie got that Oscar just take a look at
this stunning scene where Peter B Parker
and Miles Morales are swinging through
the woods miles is finally starting to
get the hang of the web slinging it's
one of the many moments where this movie
feels like a comic book come to life and
speaking of animated superheroes fans
waited 14 years between The Incredibles
and The Incredibles to that first movie
ended with the tease of baby Jack Jack's
powers emphasis on powers plural in the
seagull Jack Jack's power is went
berserk when he won head-to-head with a
raccoon he was zapping it smacking it
even tried to set it on fire really
makes me wish Pixar we get into the
superhero business full time
[Music]
marbles on-screen battles have just
gotten better and better as time has
gone on this battle for Asgard on the
Rainbow Bridge is set to Led Zeppelin's
immigrant song making it the perfect
combination of song and fight scene and
when the song gets to Valhalla I am
coming
Valkyrie long associated with Valhalla
in Norse mythology is swaggering across
the bridge to enter the fight and Thor's
other allies Loki Hulk Korg Heimdall and
the rest of Asgard are all doing their
part to take Helen and her forces down
with a brand new director Thor Ragnarok
was a breakthrough a moment for the
character on the big screen giving him
much more humor than he had before
missing an eye and the end of this movie
cap wakes up in what he thinks is the
1940s only to discover that he's been
frozen for 70 years he's eventually met
by Nick Fury the twist was executed well
and the movie also ended with one of the
most heartbreaking lines in any
superhero movie Steve Rogers would
finally get that date with Peggy and
endgame and speaking of twists in Iron
Man 3 the Mandarin who we're led to
believe is the main villain is nothing
more than an actor just a role the
Mandarin sees no real it's a clever
twist but also one of the MC use most
divisive moments this never actually
happened in the comics and if you were a
fan of them you were kind of deprived of
the chance to see Iron Man face off
against one of his oldest foes me I felt
like Marvel didn't have a whole lot of
options
it was the studio is fixed for a
character who was developed around a
whole lot of racist tropes and
stereotypes The Dark Knight Rises was
gonna have a tough time topping 2008's
The Dark Knight but it came pretty close
in this thrilling opening scene which
introduced us to Tom Hardy's Bane it's
an unforgettable opening not just
because they filmed it in real planes
and also not because all of your friends
had terrible Bane impressions after this
movie came out no one cared who I was
till I put on the mouse the script says
do a Bane voice but mine's really bad
I was bigger than the dock I can't do
one wonder woman makes her grand
entrance a bright spot in an otherwise
awful movie and a sign not fully
realized at the time that there was a
brighter future ahead for the DC
extended universe just try to get that
theme music out of your head
we're gonna come back to Wonder Woman
and a little bit before we get started
does anyone want to get out now this is
among the absolute best fight scenes in
the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe and
it's not on a giant battlefield
it's just Captain America a bunch of
Hydra soldiers and a very cramped
elevator this scene was so memorable
that it showed up again in endgame
this was by far the best of the solo
Wolverine movies it was the dark and
emotional portrayal that the character
always deserved
I could choose any action sequence from
this movie that gave it its our rating
but Logan's death really felt like
everything was coming full circle and it
was truly the end of an era
Logan's entire life has been a battle
and he can finally be at peace now give
us an X 23 movie already where's this
one from Black Panther was a
groundbreaking moment in pop culture its
Best Picture nomination can attest to
that but it's not movies hero I want to
talk about it's the villain kill monger
and his intro how do you think he
ancestors gonna be you think they paid a
fair price what are they taking what
they took everything else perhaps you're
already thinking hey is it even fair to
call this guy the villain but I see
through you
dr. strange expanded the MCU far beyond
normal fighting nowhere is that more
apparent than when dr. strange first
meets the agent one and she takes him on
quite the trip what mysteries lie beyond
the reach of your senses the visuals
feel like a call back to the original
Steve Ditko creations from the 60s and
they set up a lot of what was to come
with reality bending and time-travel
later on in MCU
Mysterio takes spider-man through a
mind-bending trip through a whole bunch
of projections it's mesmerizing
and terrifying just look at zombie Tony
Stark
this already feels like a sequence fans
will be talking about for a very long
time and other spider-man movies both
animated and live-action are gonna have
a hard time topping it and now the top 5
the 3rd Captain America movie isn't just
about cap during a pivotal battle at an
airport in Berlin
The Avengers found themselves divided on
one side we had Iron Man joined by
spider-man black panther and war machine
and on the other we had Captain America
with Falcon Winter Soldier and Giant Man
Scarlet Witch made cars fly through the
air ant-man grew to the size of a
skyscraper and spider-man made Star Wars
jokes
nice trick fat Jesus Tony how old I
don't know I didn't carbon dated this
made watching the team fall apart
completely worth it
DC got ahead of the MCU with this female
lead superhero film set during the first
world war includes this thrilling scene
set in no-man's land where Diana marches
across the battlefield drawing all the
enemy fire so the soldiers can advance
if this sequence doesn't make you a
Wonder Woman fan
nothing could so we've hit the top three
and yes it's just gonna be the Avengers
movies here on out when you think of
superhero films from the last decade or
so this is probably the first image that
comes to mind
[Music]
at that point we've been waiting for
years since the first iron man movie to
see the core Avengers all together in
one shot suited up and ready for action
and this image is just straight-up
iconic it's rare to see a superhero
movie and on such a downer but with the
snap infinity war proved itself to be
the Empire Strikes Back of Avengers
movies and we were left to wonder for an
entire year how those heroes would come
back because the movies make way too
much money to not bring them back
[Music]
this was the hardest movie to fake a
scene from so we're gonna cheat and say
the entire third act because technically
it's the ending to 21 other movies and
it delivered you have Thor cab and Iron
Man coming together for one last stand a
throwback to the first Avengers movie
when they first came together and fought
over Loki and if you saw this in
theaters
you really thought one of them was gonna
die here but no the Russos decided to
instead deliver on more than a decade of
teases and buildups
cat shows he's worthy by wielding
Mjolnir and summoning the lightning he
straps on his shield for what he thinks
will be the last time and Sam gives us a
call back to Winter Soldier to let cap
know the cavalry has arrived
Anya look it looks like all of Wakanda
is there all the Wizards are there
Valkyrie has shown up on her Pegasus
even Pepper Potts is there in the rescue
suit and Captain America delivers the
iconic battle cry that fans have been
waiting years to hear
assemblé they could have just left it at
that but nope the battle still gave us
some great moments Tony and pepper fight
back-to-back Tony finally hugs Peter
there's the gauntlet relay all the
female Avengers come together if you saw
this in theaters especially opening
weekend then you know how much the
audience cheered for each and every one
of those moments and how dusty of the
theater got for Tony's funeral that
ending is why I paid to see this movie
in theaters three times you thought
three times in theaters you didn't did
we miss any of your favorites let us
know in the comments that is magazines
[Music]